let's begin the show by starting it it's
604 am and i'm perd hapley of channel 4
eyewitness news and the story of this
next dance is that it's called the worm
[Music]
the fact is this carnival is being held
on top of an ancient wamapoke burial
site much like the house in the movie
poltergeist
exactly i spoke to leslie knope of the
parks department about moving the
carnival
and she refused we do have exclusive
animation of that event let's take a
look
oh i love these things
sorry
[Music]
[Music]
is that what happened
none of that happened
that is exactly what happened hello i'm
perd hapley and welcome to you heard
with perd today's show begins now
is this art or is it pornography here to
answer this question is parks and
recreation deputy director leslie knope
perd it is a beautiful work of art
governments should not be in the
business of censorship especially when a
painting is as awesome as this one
but this is where the controversy of
this story gets even more controversial
you are the subject of this painting
half woman
half horse with what some would say are
human breasts i am not the subject
the subject is strong and empowered
women everywhere
but it it does look a little bit like me
leslie for our viewers at home who might
not know
are centaurs real
no
you're absolutely sure for a female
perspective on this scandal we turn to a
woman leslie knope i'm about to ask you
a question right now and that question
is this the lewd photo just how big a
deal is it
well frankly perd it's not that big a
deal if you know what i
mean i don't know what you mean but
it had the cadence of a joke
this is the final word with perv with
your host perdrick l hapley
issue number one is the first issue
we're going to talk about is bobby
newport's campaign for city council in
trouble when i say your names i want you
to respond
dylan well newport's poll numbers have
been plummeting uh uh they just fired
his campaign manager and where's bobby
he's on vacation in spain he's not on
vacation he's in hiding every time the
guy speaks he puts his foot in his mouth
that's a hilarious image a foot and a
mouth
it's a
common expression
okay also joining us today is a
different person pornographic film
actress brandi max pleasure to be here
brandi you've starred in over 200 adult
films some which are very good when'd
you get in the business last year
fantastic now this painting right here
art
or pornography per i think this whole
debate is ridiculous what leslie and i
do is obviously art oh
hang on um there's a big difference
between
an oil painting of a greek myth and a
pornographic movie it's okay leslie i
got this one what leslie and i want
people to know is you should be able to
have sex anywhere you want and show it
anywhere you want whether it's girl on
girl action bondage or yep what have you
okay uh hang on pornography is very
difficult to define um in fact it was
just a steward who once said i can't
define pornography but i know it when i
see it brandy how would you define
pornography for me it's when the penis
goes in
now leslie you claim the newport
campaign stole one of your ideas
well
uh
they did they stole our idea we were
working on the ramp up pawnee initiative
for many weeks oh perd this is politics
as usual the fact is bobby newport's
plan is better for seniors better for
pawnee well our plan is more practical
and it's cheaper there she goes again
perd
i don't know where she went the first
time apparently leslie knope wielded her
insider influence and got councilman
pilner to save her precious department
even though it meant closing the shelter
now i'm not saying that leslie knope is
a dog murderer per se i just think that
her actions raise some questions like
for example is she a dog murderer oh god
well i don't know the answer to that
jennifer but your tone makes me think
yes there are some statistics that i'd
like to share with you now and they are
numbers some 85 of pawnee residents
support abstinence-only education and
the other 15 are perverts
jk you guys and 100 of pawneeans are
per-diverged that's the name i call fans
of the show based on the fact that my
name is perd perd hapley is here today
or as perd would say my name is perd
hapley and the person i see here today
is me
everyone seems to be laughing now i have
a question
for you
it's something very important which is
what is your
[Music]
spirit animal jaguar why do you ask
doing a survey
welp survey completed so take her easy
uh you didn't ask me but if you had the
answer i would have given is doggy chris
ann wants to ask you something right now
go ann
in front of herd yes no more delays go
i want to have a baby will you be the
sperm donor
the story of this situation is it's
extremely personal
it's a heartwarming story but it's just
not believable which is why i give e.t
one and a half stars do you think leslie
knope should be in england do you not
think that or do you not think that 48
said she should not be in europe 17 say
it's okay and 35 said they were confused
by the way the question was posed
i'm here live at a press conference
where councilman jeremy jam will discuss
a government scandal we are calling
twitter watergate until we can find a
snappier name for it councilwoman leslie
knope wants to put fluoride which is a
chemical into your drinking water you
know what else is a chemical strychnine
and cyanide what and dirt and rust and
even broken glass
exactly you definitely understand what
chemicals are purged we know that you
were already approached by sweetums and
you said no but is there any way you
would reconsider i'm sorry miss no there
is such a thing as journalistic
integrity and it is something that i
have as a journalist with integrity it's
really important perd please
come on roll time's sake well the story
of that appeal is it was heartfelt
and in response to that appeal i respond
okay
for old time's sake does that mean
no
and you tricky minks yup
i went on a date with perd what it was
during that exploring my freedom as a
single woman phase wow we just had a
drink
and at the end he said i am going to
kiss you now by putting my mouth on your
mouth and then i ran away it was
absolutely the right call
leslie your poll is designed to choose a
new slogan and a slogan is a series of
words that have a meaning
so true perd all of the choices for the
town slogan are wonderful but if i had
to choose my favorite it would probably
be storied past bright future well the
story of my interest level is
it's medium can i get you a drink i'll
have the joan it's a tumbler of gin and
it's got crushed aspirin around the rim
and i would just like an empty glass now
leslie i understand that what you've
brought to the show isn't a box of
objects but rather a symbolic box of
allegations well purred it's
judge perd
okay uh i think there are certain
questions uh about certain aspects of
certain parts of this situation that
require an evaluation about whether or
not this is or is not a valid argument
extremely well put excuse me judge purd
i'm ben wyatt city manager what grizzle
is doing with our private information
may not technically be illegal
but it's definitely not chill whoa
that's a serious allegation we are hella
chill and frankly if you don't like our
vibe you don't have to use our shiz well
we kind of do
i mean the internet is no longer
optional it's a necessity for everyone
and i think you do know that data mining
isn't chill because you snuck it into
the 27th update of a 500-page
user agreement
a person should not have to have an
advanced law degree to avoid being taken
advantage of by a multi-billion dollar
company
you should be upfront about what you're
doing
and allow people the ability to opt out
to be honest judge purr is stumped by
this case
i've also misplaced my judge hammer
i cannot render a verdict here therefore
i must declare a mistrial which is a
term i've heard people use in the movies
tap tap tap
you